calm has returned to the center of
almaty
though the signs of violence are
everywhere on republic square scene of
the worst of the clashes security forces
have retaken control of gutted
government buildings
but they've been food shortages and cues
at cash machines and petrol stations
with residents venturing out only for
essentials
at night when we hear explosions i'm
scared it pains me to know that young
people are dying
we are scared not just for ourselves but
for our children and other people's
children we never expected such things
could happen especially in almetti
gunfire could still be heard on friday
as military units raced through almaty's
streets
in the eastern city of
a statue of the first president nor
sultan nazarbayev was pulled down the
euphoria has now evaporated
[Music]
a police loudspeaker warns people to
stay indoors while an anti-terror
operation gets underway
[Music]
has shown little sympathy for the
protesters all calls for calm
there have been calls abroad for the
parties to move the negotiations to a
peaceful resolution what nonsense what
kind of negotiations can there be with
criminals with murderers we had to deal
with armed and trained bandits both
local and foreign
the claim without evidence that
protesters are foreign-backed terrorists
was the pretext to invite the moscow-led
security bloc to send in its forces
six 3600 csto soldiers
most of them russian peacekeepers are
being deployed
democracy activists have expressed
dismay that their calls for change have
gone unheard
the banner reads we are citizens not
terrorists
peaceful demonstrations are still taking
place
this is janao zen in the west of
kazakhstan
but legitimate protests now risk being
stamped out
by a shoot to kill policy robin
forrester walker al jazeera